jean marc sylvestre bonjour d'abord en
quoi le risque de pandémie et le climat
d'insécurité qui règne en france depuis
l'été rend la reprise de l'économie
difficile
vous savez l'économie c'est pas une
science exacte
problème aujourd'hui c'est de faire
redémarrer le système de production
français pour retrouver de la création
de richesses et surtout des emplois
techniquement on affronte finalement de
crise et c'est ça qui est compliqué
c'est que la première crise et lévis au
confinement ou plutôt au déconfinement
on avait tout arrêté
il faut tout faire reparti mais ça n'a
rien détruit on peut refaire repartir
les choses des entreprises n'ont pas été
détruites les contrats de travail ont
été préservés grâce aux allocations de
chômage partiel et l'état finalement à
apporter les fonds de trésorerie
donc finalement on a aucune raison que
ça ne redémarre par le club relance est
fait pour accompagner cette relance par
des investissements à la
réindustrialisation transition
écologique des appuis sociaux et puis
également des baisses d'impôts de
production les entreprises vont donc en
profiter il faut gérer cette sortie du
coma c'est faux c'est possible mais on a
une deuxième crise derrière on a une
deuxième crise à gérer cette crise qui
est en crise de mutation profonde de
l'économie française vous savez on a
beaucoup d'entreprises françaises qui
étaient malades avant le coc vide alors
on n'en parlait pas trop mettait la
poussière sous le tapis mais le coville
a accéléré la nécessité de réformer et
on doit ré industrialiser je les y en a
beaucoup trop délocalisé au cours des 10
ou 20 dernières années certains secteurs
digitalisées les systèmes aussi est
entré dans la transition écologique là
eh bien on n'est pas prêt on n'est pas
prêt et on craint de la casse sociale
pour dans deux mois trois ou quatre mois
dans le transport aérien par exemple
dans l'automobile c'est très clair alors
on va ajouter de l'anxiété sociale à
l'anxiété sanitaire sylvestre on le
disait tout à l'heure le plan de relance
sera présenté aujourd'hui par le premier
ministre quels sont ses points faibles
alors je sur le plan financier sur le
plan technique on a là beaucoup parlé le
gouvernement a fait le coeur bat il a
fait le job
il a mis le paquet à peu près comme les
allemands mais nous étions plus fragiles
nous sommes plus fragiles les halles
il a mis le paquet aussi au niveau
social par le système d'allocations
chômage partiel ce qui a permis de
préserver tous les contrats du travail
alors les points faibles des points
faibles
et bien c'est que nos de confinement a
sans doute été très très sévères
beaucoup plus sévère que beaucoup
d'autres pourquoi pas parce que nous
n'étions pas préparés au départ n'est
pas de masque on n'avait pas de test on
a eu pas d'organisation le sentais
suffisamment performante le confinement
à doc était nécessaire mais beaucoup
plus sévère que dans d'autres le pays
ensuite ce que nous dépendons aussi
peut-être beaucoup plus de l'étranger on
a davantage délocalisées nos industries
donc on s'est retrouvés un peu dépourvu
et puis le veut certaines industries
le tourisme par exemple dont nous
dépendons énormément c'est la première à
busté procès est bien assez me
correspond assez flagrant or les
échanges avec l'étranger ne sont pas
répartis la leur parti le système de
transports ne fonctionnent pas toujours
à plein régime parfois on a assez peu de
marges de financement salle et nono
budget était malade les marges que nous
pourrions avoir
nous viendrons de l'union européenne
d'où l'importance de l'accord qui avait
été passé par les allemands on est sur
la dette on est sûr de l'endettement
donc pour limiter l'endettement qui
serait rapidement insupportable il nous
faut absolument de la croissance pour
assurer un financement durable
on n'a pas si on n'a pas retrouvé de la
croissance l'année prochaine on va dans
le mur
jean marc silva ce que peut-on attendre
du gouvernement en plus des 100
milliards qui vont être mobilisés oui
alors si c'est ça va être ça qui est
intéressant d'ailleurs ses premiers mots
qu'il présente ça n'est pas de ministre
de l'économie donc donc ça va se situe
au niveau politique le plan qui sera
dévoilé aujourd'hui c'est un plan
destiné à relancer l'appareil de
production
l'offre ce sont les entreprises tous les
ingrédients seront sur la table
on a fait des baisses d'impôts de
production des investissements l'argent
l'objectif les chefs d'entreprise sont
sur le pied de guerre
ils attendent tous à y vante de chaud il
manque deux choses la première chose
c'est que les consommateurs ne sont
toujours pas au rendez vous les
consommateurs ont accumulé de l'est
parle beaucoup
or ils ont peur de dépenser or une
entreprise elle a besoin de tout ce dont
on a parlé de d'argent d'investissement
distincts mais les entreprises a besoin
de clients ils ont besoin de
consommateurs et aujourd'hui le
consommateur hésite à rentrer dans les
magasins
on a trouvé on a on a bien vu au
lendemain du déconfinement il y a eu une
ruée vers les concessions automobiles le
marché automobile a explosé on a
beaucoup vendu qu'il ait beaucoup de
primes de distribuer et puis après ça
s'est calmé à juillet août ça a été très
calme au niveau donc selon deux matches
de déconfinement laissait augurer une
reprise est un rebond assez fort la
réalité c'est qu'on est revenu à un
niveau beaucoup plus beaucoup plus car
je répète que si on a pas de croissance
on aura un squeeze financier la deuxième
chose très important c'est que le climat
est anxiogène les acteurs de l'économie
manque de confiance dans l'avenir il ya
virus qui roule évidemment il y a le
climat social et même sociétal qui
menace dans ces conditions on peut pas
faire de projets les chefs d'entreprises
hésitent un peu investir et surtout les
clients hésitent à acheter or l'économie
a besoin de stabilité
l'économie elle a besoin de visibilité
on n'a ni stabilité ni visibilité très
clair le gouvernement et présidence
n'ont pas réussi à calmer le jeu a
rassuré a proposé un contrat de
confiance
or ce contrat de confiance est
nécessaire à la reprise on ne fera pas
de reprise sans contrat de confiance
le problème il est évidemment politique
le gouvernement n'a toujours pas trouvé
le discours qui rassure merci jean marc
sylvestre journaliste et chroniqueur
économique